hey everyone its Jesse and today I'm
really excited that I get to start a new
brand new project as if you've all been
watching for the last month or so I've
been working on the same project and I'm
just so I'm so happy to be be finished
with the project and it I'm happy with
the way it turned out and I learned a
lot on the project and you all helped me
so much but it's good to start start
something new so I had a lot of people
give me feedback that they wanted to see
a project from the very beginning so
this this is it this is we're gonna
start from scratch you can see I have I
have nothing this is literally nothing
on the screen right now so I'm gonna
start you know here even even my
terminal is I haven't even typed one
command yet and I have a blank Trello
board so no no work at all beforehand
we're gonna start this up you know from
scratch so the first thing that we're
gonna do is I'm gonna go over what the
project is and what the requirements are
and then that's gonna be determined how
we set things up alright so since the
the point of this dream is to show what
you know what it's like for me as a
developer I want to show the whole
process so I'm not gonna jump right into
the code we need to get a little bit of
planning in as well so and I hopefully
you all can help me in that planning
process so it looks like we have a lot
of viewers right now I'm gonna try my
best to keep up with a live chat but
it's going pretty fast right now so let
me pull over my timer so we're gonna use
the last couple of shows have been using
this
timer and I'm gonna start this and then
that way every time this Pomodoro timer
goes off we'll take a five-minute break
and during that break I'll make sure I'd
catch up on as much of the live chat as
I possibly can and then during the other
25 minutes I'll try to dedicate that
mostly to focusing on the task at hand
so hey everyone and I see a lot of a lot
of people saying hi let me show you so
here's what the project is going to be I
want I already know ahead of time I want
to do this and react and I just said
somebody said in the the Instagram feed
so I the secondary feed for this dream
is on Instagram and it's the view of my
face as I'm coding and I just had a
question in there it was from some from
one of my former students and he asked
who is your favorite X student so and
that's from from D tribe that was of
course his nickname but D trav since no
since none of my other students are
watching this dream right now
I'm gonna say you were one of my
favorites now I don't I can say that
without lying at all I really did like
having you in my classes so you're a
good guy so anyway thanks for watching
so I hope everything's going well with
you but I'm gonna get to work now so
anyway I know I want to do this project
and react because I've been working in
reactants on a course and react right
now some future sites are gonna be in
react so if you're tired of me doing
things in react I'm sorry it's gonna be
more react unless there's some really
really good reason that you all can come
up with why I should do this using
something else it's probably going to be
a react project so let me explain what's
going on so my very first project here
at this job almost two years ago my
first project was to make what they
called a resource center so I work in
the marketing department and
we do a lot of things for all the
departments here on campus at this
university so we were constantly getting
requests from people lots of people in
different departments and we we just
didn't keep track of them well and
sometimes things would fall through the
cracks you know if we're getting at each
request sometimes it would be you just
happen to pass somebody by when you're
you know walking from one building to
another and they mentioned something or
a phone call or email so you'd see how
it easily would get overwhelming and
then there's no record of what we you
know what we did so my original goal was
to come up with some system where we
could track everything where people
could submit you know what they wanted
us to do and also where they could get
resources that they were constantly
asking us for like logos they could just
go on and get it themselves without
having to email people or call people so
I did that and it worked it was great
but now it's time to redo it and update
it so let me show you the old one to
give you an idea of what we're working
with and what we need and so I'm gonna
pull this over on the screen let me make
it a little bigger and so this this is
our current I guess kind of internal
site this runs on it's called J ICS so a
company called Jenzabar makes this for
for higher education for universities so
this is the homepage I did not design
this I'm not gonna say any more about it
but it was not me I'm gonna log in and
show you the part of this that I did
design and so
let me just tell you when I click this
basically I do some things with z-index
to where the the page that comes up just
hides all the stuff that's behind it it
goes in front of it so you can see
there's definitely some weird stuff
going on when it loads but this is it
all right so yeah yeah let's take the
live chat I'm there so that really was
the menu yeah can you believe that
yeah so it's I think that's safe to say
that the UI for that is terrible I don't
think I'm gonna offend anybody here at
the University I think it's the there's
a general consensus that UI is terrible
so the good news is that that UI is
gonna change the bad news is I'm gonna
have to redo all what I've already done
because Jenzabar has finally decided
that it's a good idea to have a
responsive website so I'm really glad
because it's 2017 and they're finally
having a responsive site so they're
coming down they're coming out with
their version 9 which totally will
conflict with any custom themes that
have been done so far so I've been
seeing that the only real way to get
information about Jenzabar stuff is on
their listserv it's crazy this company
is just like I don't know like straight
out of the 90s and never changed and
I've been seeing over the listserv a lot
of people have been having trouble when
they've upgraded with their UI just
breaking so I'm expecting that to happen
so I've decided that I'm not gonna try
to develop it within here because let me
show you this is how I have to edit it I
have to actually go into here let me
show you the Javas fits here so
I need to go in
let me find see it's crazy I can't even
find what I'm supposed to find let me
refresh literally if I want to make any
edit I have to copy and paste into here
into these little text boxes so I'll
show you again you can see it's it's so
frustrating I mean I've spent hours on
this and it's still hard to remember the
sequence of clicks that I have to go
through so let me show you well I don't
see I'm not even sure why that well so I
can't even I actually can't even click
them I can't even show you where the the
boxes to edit this because evidently
this entire page now has become a link
to canva so you can see the frustration
and trying to develop this so I am
definitely not going to try to make what
I made work with whatever a new system
they come out with so that's out of the
question
we're definitely we're doing this it's
going to be hosted most likely on a
digitalocean server and I'm just gonna
link to it from within this they call it
my Franciscan but this kind of a
university intranet alright so these are
the main things that we need this this
site to do the some of these are just
links so this brand manual this is just
a link to PDF super easy so it needs to
be able to link to resources we need to
be able to let people download different
versions of our logos so this is what I
have set up this is using I think
isotope or masonry yeah so just has two
logos you can download
different versions of the logos and it
does the so anyway that's that's one of
the main features I think the poster one
is simply some links and some
information not a big deal
letterhead is also just some some
samples some images not a big deal I'm
just going to skip ahead the rest is
pretty much the same a lot of text the
only thing that's gonna be a little bit
of a big deal is this form so the form
is actually going to change a little bit
we want to change this wording but as I
said I'm I'm holding off on making any
updates to this until we totally redo it
because I'm I'm not gonna try to go
through the the headache of you know
copy and pasting every change so
basically we just we need a form we need
that form to be to be able to upload
files and then we need the data from the
form to go directly into our project
management system which we use rike for
project management so it needs to go
into rike and it also needs to send out
an email to the person that's submitted
saying that hey we your submission went
through and then it also needs to send
out an email to someone here in my
department saying that someone submitted
something okay so those are the basic
you know just the very basic things that
it needs to do so this is not gonna be
you know really really difficult project
now I'm open to changing anything in
this UI so you can see this was early on
this was before I kind of refined the
brand standards for this university and
but it basically adheres to a lot of
what we're doing you know you can see
material design elements here you can
see it has you know some of the proper
shadows and things border-radius so it
has familiar elements to some things but
if i'm going to redo it I may as well
update the UI I don't want to make it I
don't want to really startle people but
if the UI for my franciscan is gonna
change
completely it shouldn't be that big of a
deal if this UI also changes because
people will most likely expect it to
change if everything else is changing as
well I currently do have all the other
links to things in my Franciscan
here.these I probably won't be able to
pull these over and I don't really know
that I would I even want to if we're
gonna make a new a new site that's not
within my Franciscan so anyway that's
the that's it I mean that's that's the
project requirements
I have probably I'm gonna say like three
weeks do I want to try to get this done
in you know give it give or take a week
so I'm gonna go to the live chat I want
to see what you all think based on what
I said so here's here's what I would
like your opinion on I'd like to know
well one is there any really good reason
why I should not use react I'm I'm like
99% sure I want to use react but just in
case there's something I'm overlooking
then you know I'm open to that also
should I use next j/s like we did for
the last project or should I use
something else like create react app or
should I
I really do actually I don't want to
attempt to do it completely from scratch
and set up a web pack config and
everything because I just don't think I
have enough time to really learn that
properly maybe I'll save that for for a
later project but I'm kind of thinking I
ought to just use next j/s I'm really
familiar with it I could develop quickly
with that I don't necessarily need the
server-side rendering this is not a site
that I need to be indexed by search
engines
the routing that comes with it would be
nice but there's not a whole lot of
routing that needs to happen right now
this is all just I didn't show any the
code for this but this is all
jQuery even the routing is with jQuery
so these they have hashes for the links
and they all work so you can actually go
to you know to the URL assuming that you
had a login and it would take you the
right spot so that was all custom jQuery
routing but let me look at let me look
at some of your responses I see there's
a lot of stuff in here let's see oh I'll
see if there's any questions - I guess
I'll answer them now I wonder what I'm
not
yeah I'm not not quite to the time yet
for questions but since I asked you all
so many questions I'm just gonna check
the live chat now yes some people were
commenting on how many people were
waiting they were actually at 10 people
waiting at one point for this for the
video that was really awesome while
we're up to a decent number of years to
163 that's well above what we normally
get so I assume there's some new people
here watching for the first time so
welcome and please feel free to join in
a live chat if you can your I really
value your opinion and helping to figure
out how we're gonna do these projects so
I have some questions where are you from
I'm from originally I'm from West
Virginia in the United States but now I
live in Ohio I'm actually right on the
border of Ohio so I'm closer to
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania you may know
that's kind of a bigger city so you may
know where that is
someone asks do you go live I do stream
every weekday unless something comes up
where I can't like on Monday I I wasn't
working so but I try to stream every
weekday at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
let's see I'm skipping over some stuff
here I will go back through though and
at the end and try to answer as many
questions as I can
Earl asks do you charge for services on
your campus no we currently don't charge
for the services on the campus although
I I am I think as a department we should
charge and that would give people a
better idea of how much things actually
cost and whether or not it's a good idea
because I think right now people just
think okay we're starting a new thing we
want video we want print materials we
want an email campaign and a new website
and all the stuff because they never see
the bill for that necessarily I mean
they have to pay for the printing and
things but I I think it would people
would be more realistic about what's
what's possible what's reasonable if
they did have to pay someone mentioned
that I am salaried yes I am salaried
here okay the someone mentioned that the
microphone is buzzing it's probably my
phone I'll try to move my phone a bit
farther away let me know if the mic is
is still buzzing I moved it a bit
I see yes so people were saying it makes
them want to cry when they saw that
sight yeah that was the first thing I
saw when I came here my very first
project and I was just it's amazing that
I stayed
all right so I'm getting to so there's
just so much in the live chat going on
I'm I'm trying to find I know I saw some
people give me suggestions about what we
should build this in here we go Santa
said if you need an app - why not
refactor in react native it would be
cool actually to make this an app that
would be really cool okay so you have
people saying yeah you use react
some people said in XJS okay pre-act
create RAC react app don't reinvent the
wheel create that okay so we had some
people a lot of people saying create
react app
okay maybe we'll do that then we'll use
create react at all right let's do that
it looks like we had a lot of people
saying use create react app so I'm gonna
go with that we're gonna use create
react app and then we'll use we don't
need anything crazy for routing so we'll
just use basic like reactor outer and I
think that'll work
that should work yeah so I will say this
this is going to be a more of a learning
experience for me because I do have a
lot more experience with next j/s more
so than I do with create react app so
I'm gonna be learning along with you I
am using create react app in my react
course that I'm doing right now and
that's the one from Udacity so I'm not
and I have used it before so I had up on
my screen oh here we go
I had it ready basically I had the neck
next and create react app ready to go so
we can kind of walk through some of the
installation process let's so let's also
start I'm gonna show you how we how at
least I plan out my projects so I'm
gonna do it to do ready ready for dev in
progress testing and done and then
wishlist okay so we're just gonna make
some basic cards so it's gonna be
and whenever I do things I always put an
estimate so I'm gonna include some other
setup things in there that's what I'm
saying it's gonna take I estimate how
many Pomodoro cycles everything will
take so let's see see what else you want
to do I kind of don't want to break down
everything right now yeah I'm gonna
unless somebody really wants to see this
I'm gonna fill out these cards
afterwards because I'd like to get
pretty detailed and all the steps and
that will probably take a long time it
won't be that fun to watch so since we
are gonna work on this today I'll just
fill this one out and I'll move it two
in progress but the idea is I take all
the tests I know I need to do is tomato
how much time it's gonna take and then I
move them along the process and when
it's done I also say how much time it
really took and I don't think this is
public now but I'll make this public so
y'all can see it as well all right so
let's take to make I'm gonna make the
font size a bit bigger so y'all can see
and this is just the create react app
github repo if you want to follow along
so let's go through the setup process
I want to keep all of my projects in a
projects folder and let's say the
Resource Center yeah okay so I'm not
gonna use NPM I'm gonna use yarn so
let's go yarn if you're not familiar
with yarn well if you're not familiar
with NPM at all this is a way to install
node modules so nodejs is a way to use
JavaScript server-side and not just in
the browser and so NPM is the way that
you pull in different little bits of
code that people have written and
packaged up in these little modules so
you pull them in with this command line
tool called a node package manager or
NPM yarn it basically does everything
that NPM does but it adds a few extra
features one thing it does is it seems
to be a bit faster and it keeps better
track of like the exact versions of
things so for now if you're new just
know that you can use yarn or NPM
interchangeably and they'll both they'll
work so I'm gonna pull in this create
react app NPM package so I'm gonna go
yarn add so just a little bit different
create react app and I don't think I
have
I'm not gonna worry about installing
this globally right now I'm not really
sure how many times I'll use this we'll
see how it goes with this project
alright so actually let me see if this
created I'm going to open this up an
atom it should have yep it did okay so
we have now a package.json file with
this dependency of create react app I
didn't fill out anything else from the
package.json file but I can always do
that later on and now let's create the
app so we'll type in create react app
and then we're gonna name it I should
have done I should have done this one
level up oh wow
alright it looks like the mic is still
buzzing so I'm gonna move I'm gonna move
my my phone try to get it farther away
I made you soft I had it plugged in
charging right now but I may just have
to keep it unplugged and move it like
really far away all right let me know if
that's it yeah okay Sebastian I see your
thing so I did realize this so I let me
let me just go back because I messed
this up I really should have installed
this globally and I wasn't thinking when
I first did it so dang it and I wasn't
thinking then I got sidetracked and
typed in so let's let me go back out
here oops
so I'm gonna remove recursively
everything in that Resource Center
folder all right so now I am gonna do
this properly and they already have this
installed nice I think it's on my laptop
I don't think I installed it here right
now I'm working on an iMac okay so now
let's try this again the correct way
now's a great time to give my normal
disclaimer that this is entirely live
and not rehearsed so you will see all of
my mistakes I do my best to not make
them but as you know like everyone I'm
not perfect so we'll make mistakes and
you'll see that hopefully you all can
learn from my mistakes along with me and
maybe you know you won't make them
because I've already done it create
react and now we're gonna call this
center resource sensor today let me make
this a bit bigger I just occurred to me
that this was still pretty small all
right so now this is doing its thing
it's installing so if you're gonna if
you want to try this out and read all
this insulation stuff you can but
basically it's just it's installing
everything that we need to build a react
site all right so while that's running
I'm gonna come back and catch up a bit
with a live chat I think my timer did go
off let me find it here yeah it did and
I I didn't click the break so the short
break so let me take a few minutes I'm
going to go back through and try to
answer some questions especially if
anyone's new he asked some questions
definitely want to get to your questions
hey everyone yeah I'm seeing a lot of
new people so welcome I really
appreciate you watching and feel free to
ask any questions I'll try to get to as
many questions as I can
and
[Music]
don't worry if you're new and you're not
sure what's going on I'm happy to
explain anything so just let me know
let's see rah rah choo says can you
please train us with some Java projects
I don't do anything with Java at least
not for years I haven't done anything
with Java so I won't be doing anything
with that
Carlos asked with terminal I'm using its
I term I think it's I turn to so yeah it
should say yeah I term to Earl says very
cool that you're doing this for everyone
thank you thanks for saying that
hopefully you all can get something
beneficial out of this I know I do from
all of your input I get Kaz Kazik I
can't pronounce that but if the first
part is Kazakh says hey Jesse many
thanks for what you're doing you're
welcome thank you so much for watching
and for saying that Park Ryan says love
free code can't live awesome I love that
you're watching thank you for saying
that
Philip said marketing something Philips
and marketing as well I I think I
remember talking about that before with
you
I just saw Raunak said from 1995 to 2017
in one click yes so this when I went
from the from the one site into what I
had done for it yeah everybody was
really surprised whenever I built that
it kind of caused I don't know if I want
to say trouble exactly but it was like
it caused trouble in that other
departments then immediately wanted
similar things for their sections of it
and so that kind of caused trouble
because people were asking
they were asking the people who were in
charge of that site to do the same thing
that I did and it just so it was a
little bit weird I was happy that
everybody liked it so much but it was
there's a little bit of tension over it
okay so this would work so I'm I didn't
get through all the all the live chat
because there's so much in there right
now which is which is awesome I think
that's that's so great you all are so
active in the chat I just see Umberto's
comment
it says mumbles dotnet core with react
test Hut net so yeah I'm not gonna be
doing any done that stuff anytime soon
although the we do have some sites that
run on dotnet that I'll probably need to
be doing something with so it's possible
there might be some dotnet stuff
happening so I'm gonna go back let's see
I guess my 5 minutes isn't up so let me
I said I'd give 5 minutes to live chat
so as soon as that timer's up I'll go
back to it let's see okay so Scottie
says Scottie is new so hey welcome
welcome Ron access new awesome
Mehmet says I don't understand how devs
can allow client-side rendering because
my first rule was never to trust the
client yeah I mean there's benefits to
doing client-side rendering so I mean I
wouldn't obviously the the best I like
to do both to have server-side rendering
and client-side then you get the
benefits of each so you know that's my
preference but I certainly I don't like
to render everything client-side unless
there's no other way which there's
usually another way all right so yeah I
didn't get through everything in the
chat but I'm gonna go back over to here
so we can kind of get through some stuff
and I'll I'll come back into the chat I
did just want to get through that first
part because once we get a lot of
messages I won't be able to read the
stuff that you all put in the live chat
earlier on all right so let's check out
the message that has given us here
success awesome we created resource
center inside that directory okay so
it's telling us the commands that we can
use and using yarn as well so we can
start our dev server which is yarn start
we can build our files if we need to
which we don't need we won't need to do
that for a long time and okay we can run
tests and then if we want to I don't
know that we're gonna have to do this
but we might at some point we might need
to do this and we might need to use yarn
eject and when we do that then we're
going to be able to configure things a
lot more than we can now so create react
app is it's really nice because it gets
you started with things without needing
to know anything about webpack or all
the build tools that you're using but
the you have to give up some of the
freedom to customize in order to get
that and if you don't eject then you can
take advantage of all the updates that
come out but once you checked then you
have to handle some of that stuff on
your own
so we'll see we might need to eject at
some point I'm thinking possibly to
handle some of like the file upload
things because what I've used I have you
some things in the past that I'll need
to do like some custom stuff with so
we'll see if we can make it through
without having to eject that would be
ideal but I'm not opposed to doing it
alright so as they say we could start by
seeding into resource center so let's do
it and then typing in yarn start so
let's see what port
we're starting the dev server showed up
in this little tiny window alright so
here we go
so here it is as you can see it didn't
take that long it would have been really
really fast if I hadn't to spend so much
time messing it up and then talking but
in very you know very small amount of
time and effort we now have a react site
and it works I love that little
animation that's cool
we actually we also have this available
in the network which I didn't realize
that the last time I built that I didn't
even know so that's really cool
so obviously this is not what we're
gonna keep so we're gonna get rid of all
of this and everything but it's good to
know that at least it's it's working so
let's check out what code we have now in
that let's see and I think I'm just
gonna exit this because I set our old
stuff that when I messed it up and I'm
gonna duplicate this tab because this is
going to stay open with our server but
then now I can't do anything on it so
I'm gonna duplicate that so now I'm in
here and I want to see I'm going to type
in atom and then dot and that's gonna
open up atom and let's get rid of these
welcome guides and let's see what we
have let me make the font a bit bigger
all right so here's our package JSON
file if you're not familiar with this
this is the file that it lets us know a
little bit about the project and what
dependencies that we're using so like
what other packages so essentially when
we have a package JSON our project is
now an NPM module no we're not really
worried about most of the time nobody's
gonna download our stuff as a module
rafe we're just trying to create a site
but the official name and everything is
you know this is kind of like an NPM
module how it would normally be set up
so
we're not really worried about I I don't
worry too much about editing kind of
this this up here what we want to worry
about more our dependencies and our
scripts we're not gonna change anything
right now
at some point later on we might though
we might want to add in some you know
some things to process or CSS well we'll
see we'll see what we need as we go on
and let's see it did make a readme for
us right now
this readme has a lot of stuff a lot of
stuff about create react app so at some
point we'll probably do a proper readme
for for our project but for now I'm
gonna leave this in here and possibly
refer to it if necessary and let's see
what else do we have the yarn lock is a
file you'll probably you'll never want
to update this manually and then you
have your git ignore so this is gonna so
we're gonna use git for this project but
this is going to tell get the files that
it doesn't need to worry about tracking
okay so this is pretty standard you
generally don't want to track your node
modules and depending on what you're
using for your project you might have
different things that you're not going
going to track so the next step
is let's check out our source and so I
want to open up some of the pages so
this is our index j/s okay so all this
is doing is pull import importing some
things and then we're rendering the app
component so let's check out our app
component so we have a tas and this is
where we start to see like things that
actually look like HTML and this is
called JSX so it does look like HTML but
it behaves a little bit differently so
we use classname instead of class that's
kind of a big obvious thing right off
the bat and then we can actually put
JavaScript inside of brackets so this
logo here is actually a JavaScript you
know variable we're calling on we've
imported logo from the logo dot from
logo dot SVG so those are just a few of
the different things and we can see we
can change change some things so I'm
going to add some exclamation points
because I'm super excited and I'll show
you see now we have the exclamation
points so that's the file that we're
gonna start editing first and at this
point what we want to do is I guess we
should set up our argot let's set up get
first because I want you all to be able
to see all this code normally I'd
actually wait a little while to set up
get because I do so like some just basic
stuff to set up the project but in this
case I think it would be better if you
all could see and interact with all of
the code so let's do that now so we're
gonna do get in it
and that's gonna make this a git repo
all right so now let's do git commit let
me let me do status just to show you all
right so we have the skit status so we
have these files that are untracked
right and notice that these aren't all
the files in our project so those ones
that were in the get ignore aren't
listed here so we're gonna do a git add
and I'm gonna press just put a period
there and that's gonna add everything
and now if we look at our status you can
see we have green so now we're ready to
go
to add all of this so I'm gonna go get
commit and I'm just gonna do the EM flag
which means I can put the message right
here in line for this commit and I'm
just gonna say and that this is our
initial commit and there we go so now
this is a git repo let's set up the repo
on github so that you all can see what's
going on so I want to go into my github
actually we should I'm gonna do this in
the github for my for my department so
let's go
just make a new repository Resource
Center okay so we're gonna have a new
repo called Resource Center and
all right so just a quick description
we're gonna make this public there's no
reason right now that this should be
private there I am gonna have some API
keys and things later on that I'm going
to need to use but I'm gonna use it
server-side and I'll use environment
variables that won't get shared in the
repo and then that way I can still share
all the code without worrying about
sharing API keys so when we get to that
part I'll hopefully I'm able to do that
in a stream because I think that's an
important step if you've never done that
it's good to know so you don't
accidentally share you know keys that
that should not be shared so we're not
we don't need to read me because we
already have one the same thing with the
gate ignore we don't you know we don't
need one license I'm not really worried
about a license right now let's see so
let's create this repo alright now we
have an existing repository so we want
to push that from the command line so
we're gonna copy this this git remote
add origin alright so basically we're
setting up our remote here at this
address and then we're just gonna push
everything up to github so here's our
first command and then here's our second
there we go and let's check out the repo
alright awesome so here's our repo as I
said are the readme has like everything
from the create react a premie which
we're going to take out at some point
but for now that's in there it shows our
first commit it shows our code so it's
just like our App J s so you can even
see where we added the three exclamation
points so there you go so now you can
you can look at this I'm gonna paste
this URL for the repo into the live chat
and then I will be putting this in the
description for the video for every
video so that you all can see it so
there it is in the live chat and let me
I'm gonna check my timer okay
let me move let me move this off and
let's bring this in since this is where
we're gonna be doing you know we want to
see the work so we have to we have to
come up with our how we want this layout
to be how it's designed to be now we
have some brand guidelines that we need
to follow we already have how it looks
now
so we just need to kind of determine
well how do you really want this to look
also we got to make another decision
here and I need your help on this one
because I'm I know what probably should
be done but I don't know if I'm ready to
do it and here's the thing I've used
materialised framework for all my CSS
but it's based off of jQuery and it's
not good to modify the Dom with jQuery
when you're using react you want to
modify it in the react way preferably
using state to rerender things so do I
use materialize framework again and just
just deal with the fact that I'm gonna
have some jQuery do I try to use
materialized but don't use any of the
parts that use jQuery or do I try to
just completely do it from scratch doing
it from scratch is going to take a long
time it would be cool to try to convert
maybe use materialized but then convert
some of the stuff that it has I'm not
really sure or is there another library
that I should just try to use instead I
haven't seen a material design react
library that I would that I really liked
they've always been things about the
ones that I've seen that we're kind of
like deal breakers for me I didn't want
to use it so I'm gonna go to the chat
I'm gonna see what you all think about
that before I make a decision on this
because I mean I'm at the point really
where I'm going to start
countenance oh if I if I'm going to use
a framework I need to know because my
markup is going to be based off of that
framework
alright okay I got a lot of suggestions
here let me actually bill said you plan
on using tests for this project actually
I hadn't even thought of it but that's a
great idea I have not used tests very
often at all so maybe I should I do want
to learn how to do tests so maybe now is
the time to start maybe this is the
project where I finally do all those
things that I know are good ideas but
I've always put off because of tight
deadlines so we'll see all right so we
have material UI so these are some
suggestions for alternate to materialize
CSS so there's a material you I react
materialize ok another suggestion for
react materialized bootstrap right look
at another suggestion for react
materialize Wow okay
okay so it seems like if I'm gonna go
with the framework the most votes in the
live chat go to react materialize so let
me bring that up right now so everyone
can see what we're talking about
let's check it out react materialize let
me see
looks like I've already gone there
alright so this is what we see react
materialize alright this is at least
this would be consistent I suppose if
it's based off of materialized
it'd be consistent with what we've done
before I'm assuming some of the markup
and classes would be the same I'm also
assuming that for sure they're not using
any jQuery I think it's safe to assume
that we'll see okay I need to see let's
see what the forms okay not bad
I'm liking this so far this would have
been helpful in our last project if you
remember we had some trouble with our
selects okay see how the date picker on
nice nice great okay and oh my job was
good let's see I want to see if it says
for sure that it's not using jQuery this
has actually come a lot farther along
than when I first looked at it so I'm
really impressed with this now I mean
maybe I just didn't do a very good job
of looking at it all but I thought the
last time I checked which has been quite
a while that it didn't have nearly this
this much so I do want to verify that
they are not loading Jake hey folks and
it looks like alright jQuery is being
loaded
let me see if let me check that github
page does any Canadian does anybody know
for sure how do you use this and does
react materialize actually use jQuery or
is that being loaded for something else
on that page oh it does say alright
Carlos I see that thank you
I think Carlos answered my question
before you even ask that
so thanks for being so on top of things
all right so we're Lee getting started
let's see
yeah
all right well it looks like I was
really really excited about this but
this is not what we want what we want is
this without the jQuery and I know it's
got to be possible right I mean there's
nothing special about jQuery that that
can't be done in react so yeah we're
going to it's going to have to be a note
for react materialize I feel really
really bad about that because it looks
so promising I was actually like have
been really considering trying to
contribute to this too because I I want
to do this as well and I didn't want to
just start my own thing if they're
already doing this but if that I don't
know if they intend to try to make do it
without jQuery or not if that's their
intention and they need help I'd be
happy to try to do that but for now I
just don't yeah
alright so I'm not going to use that
what was try material UI
let's see
and here's material UI
let's see some of the components I'm
actually I'm really interested in the
form components since we will have a
form nice to see text fields okay it
looks good let's see how the code looks
all right that's pretty clean
before I go any further I'm gonna check
right away and see what is being loaded
these are songs for other stacks yes I
cool all right that's good let's um
let's see
date we I think we do use a date picker
okay cool that looks good
it's select that's what it's crazy I'm
looking everywhere and this is an
alphabetical order it shouldn't be that
difficult okay that's not that I like
that okay
I'm liking this so far let's see I'm
gonna get a lot really quick to see if
someone has contributed some important
information before I commit to this but
I think this is going to be what we go
with okay Greg is asking please say if
you're going to start doing tests I'm
listening the background I really want
to start testing myself I always have
issues doing a setup well I guess I
probably should start doing tests this
is going to be a small project so it's
probably better to start with something
small so I'm gonna try to start doing
tests I can't guarantee that it'll be
that helpful to you since I am not that
familiar with tests but I'm gonna try
try my best to do some tests
Josh Arnold this video will be available
after after I'm done
streaming so the the secondary stream on
Instagram is over now you can only
stream for an hour so just to let let
everyone know in case you are wondering
so I did have some some viewers in there
this time and so that that will be
available for 24 hours in case anyone
cares what I look like not sure why you
would care but maybe
Earl Lewis says isn't jQuery dead no
it's not dead you might call it a zombie
so it's I think it's more undead like
it'll always be around it'll note you
can never really get rid of it I don't
really have that much of a problem with
jQuery it's just when you use jQuery
with react then you you mess things up
with I don't want to get this wrong I
always say the wrong thing help me out
everyone its virtual dorm right react
has a virtual dome I always accidentally
call it a shadow Dom and I don't think
that's the right term react has a
virtual dome which is like a copy of the
the Dom and if you change something in
the Dom without doing it the react way
then reacts it doesn't have an exact
copy of the Dom so it messes things up
okay um Maxime asks what's the timer
it's a Pomodoro timer so for right now
I'm using the Pomodoro timer to help me
get an idea of like how long I'm doing
things through my normal work I time
everything I do with this and I it helps
me to break up my work and estimate
things better but then during the stream
this helps me to remember to stop what
I'm doing and go to the live chat and
then also to stop looking at the live
chat and do my work
okay and it looks like reacts we have
some people talking about react toolbox
now what's reacts okay cool it is
virtual Dom so I got it right this time
all right let me check out react toolbox
since I just had a lot of people talk
about react toolbox yeah maxime a anyway
yeah the timer
it's just tomato timer calm so tomato -
timer calm really simple it works for me
there are some some ones out there with
different features but I don't need all
the other features so that one just
works fine for me it's right you know
right in the browser what am I looking
at material I'm just gonna very quickly
look at react toolbox because I don't
want to spend too much more time on this
I mean it's definitely important thing
to spend time on because this is going
to determine a lot of you know what we
do from here on out but yes your view
for materials and components hmm
okay
I like that it looks nice
this looks good but do they have it
doesn't look like there's a lot of
components though but maybe I'm missing
something but I'm not seeing like a
select
all right
okay mobbin says material UI has tests
and github so i guess that's better
material UI is fine let's see on your i
guess what are you making how is react
useful i'm making basically a website
that needs to users can go on there
download PDFs and images and then also
they can upload files and send
information with an online form
actually I've actually been meaning to
update this with some other cool things
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna commit to
anything right now but I do have some
ideas to make it a bit more interactive
particularly like maybe giving users the
ability to check on the status of their
submissions and possibly even edit them
so not 100% sure if I can do that
through the right API that's our project
management system but I've I've thought
that possibly that would be cool to do
Oh Sebastian says look at the drop down
in react toolbar
oh okay so basically the drop down is
like the select I see alright since I
can't decide here's gonna be the decider
whatever project has more stars on
github that's the one I'm gonna go with
I don't know if that's the best way but
I don't have time to do any more
research here on the stream so that's
what I'm gonna go with so let's check
out the github repos for each one I
appreciate everyone giving their input
so let's see all right so we got 27,000
stars and this one has only 6,000 all
right so I mean I guess I guess it's
pretty it's much different here
all right so I guess we're going with
material you I my reasoning also behind
the number of stars is that probably
means more people are using this and
there's more like there'll be more stuff
on Stack Overflow about it if more
people are using it so if I need help I
can find it so it's not entirely without
a foundation there but assuming that the
two frameworks are pretty much you know
similar and what they offer I'd rather
go with the one that's used by more
people just to have that kind of that
community that I can go to for
information so let's do this let's
install material UI now to do we want to
do the pre-release
I don't know maybe I'll just stick with
the stable one
okay
I wish my so let's do this let's go what
was it again I think it's just material
you uh yep so let's go yarn add material
UI
my chef seen this react tap event
plug-in I had issues with this before I
think someone who watches the these
streams asked me to check out an error
they were having and it was related to
this react tap event plug-in I'm gonna
have to go back through maybe like my
Twitter messages and see what that was
because I don't want this to I don't
want this to mess us up as well so I've
definitely had this error before and
I've figured out some way to fix it I
mean it's not an error right now it's
just a warning but in the case where I
saw it before it was actually messing
things up quite a bit so I don't
remember who it was though if it's
someone watching right now let me know I
have otherwise I'll have to look back
through so hopefully it won't be an
issue
it's good good material UI
all right so for now everything's going
to happen just on the master branch and
this isn't even live at all at the point
where this goes live then everything
will switch over to a development branch
if you're doing any like really crazy
changes we'll have another branch for
that so for now if any of you are
interested in submitting any pull
requests like you'll want to obviously
we only have one branch now so it's I
guess it's a no-brainer but just to let
you know eventually it'll end up being a
dead branch so if anyone's really
interested in getting you know some
contributions for your github profile
I'm definitely open to that right now
there's really not much going on but
once we get started there'll be some
more obvious things ways to contribute
so and I don't expect anyone to take
time out of their day to contribute to
my projects but if you'd like to I do
appreciate it all right so let's go to
the here's a quick example
so I've never used this so I'm gonna
have to go through how to use it as well
okay here's that react tap event thing
okay so we're gonna have to just inject
this tap event alright so let me move
this over here and we'll look at the
code whoops I guess it was I on the
break and I've started I can't remember
what I was doing alright I guess I'm
going to go back to the live chat for
five minutes now then since I haven't
gone there in a while I don't want to
lose all the things at the top of the
chat I'm already starting to lose some
of it so anyway yeah so for now for the
next five minutes I'm gonna be going
through live chat stuff get some more
new people I see welcome thanks for
watching
Sushil s are you starting a whole
project from scratch
yep starting everything from scratch
this time ahmad s says first time in
here thanks for doing this Jesse you're
welcome thanks for watching Shriram says
yeah there are lots of new people will
be awesome if you can explain from
basics if you can okay yeah I'll do I'll
do my best to try to explain everything
in terms of just the stream in general I
think I mentioned this before but I'll
mention it again for new people coming
in the whole this stream is just me
doing my normal work I work at a
university I'm a front-end developer so
it's not rehearsed beforehand you will
see me make a ton of mistakes and
together with your input we're gonna
build some cool stuff and this is
definitely not a tutorial and I'm not
claiming that I have the right way to do
things either so just realize that I'm
learning and learning how to do react
and I'm always trying to learn and do
new things so it's not going to be like
the place to go to get a step-by-step
tutorial but it's definitely going to be
if you want to know what it's like at
least for me day-to-day as a front-end
developer then this is a good place to
go we've built up a nice community here
in the chat so people are very helpful
if you have questions feel free to ask
them I'll try to get to as many
questions as I can
you can put questions in the comments
too and you can direct message me on
Twitter if you like as well I try to get
to everybody's questions as soon as I
can
I think that's it hey that's my normal
with the normal stuff that I say so if
you're new you should be all caught up
then and you know what the stream is all
about
sort of ask any plan for small react
project from scratch yeah it would be
cool to do some videos and just do a
really really basic project from scratch
this is going to end up this is going to
be a small project so it's kind of gonna
be like that it'd be cool to do a video
where I do the entire project start to
finish including everything maybe one
day I'll do that this is not gonna be it
there's nothing any stuff that I do
that's I don't stream just because I
need to work on this
you know while I'm at work and I'm not
gonna stream the entire day the RAF says
I'm new to programming so I wondered
what if you have that's the most
important honestly I think if you're
starting out the most important thing is
just keep keep going don't get
discouraged always keep learning so yeah
that would be the most important thing
like just always keep learning and
trying new things if you ever get to the
point where you feel satisfied like you
don't need to learn any new things then
that's a bad thing I think that's that's
a sign that you stagnated so anyway and
if you're new like feel free to ask any
questions anything I'll try to help you
out however I can we have some people
clubs in from Los Angeles Kevin from
Trinidad awesome welcome sport Fitness
is oh is Ohio not in the United States
maybe I don't maybe I don't remember
saying it wasn't he wasn't in there but
possibly the way I said it made it seem
like that so sorry about that
definitely unintended I don't even
remember how I said it but
let's see Arvin says new from India
awesome welcome must be pretty late in
India what is it in India like 1 o'clock
in the morning a little after 1 o'clock
in the morning so everyone from from
India and from those time zones over
there thanks for staying up so late to
watch Scotty says retiring vet looking
to get into coding will welcome and
definitely I'm if you have any questions
or anything I'm more than happy to help
you there's actually an organization
just for veterans that looking to get
into coding so if you're interested in
that send me a message on twitter the my
twitter info is in the description and i
can hook you up i met the guy that's in
charge of that organization at a
conference so if you're interested i can
i you know get you hooked up with that
organization as well so and yeah i
definitely I'd be happy to to help a
veteran in any way that I can brownie
says new from Israel awesome
welcome CRM says can we text you in
Facebook for some small tips yeah yeah
feel free so you guys feel free to
follow me on any social media things if
you check if you check my youtube
channel I have most of my social media
stuff linked from there so if whatever
you're comfortable in follow me in that
social media channel and then I can you
can ask me questions there so I'm on
pretty much everything yeah I'm on
pretty much everything unless there's
some like really new social media stuff
that I don't know about yet but
otherwise most people ask me questions
on Twitter and that's cool but if you're
not really into Twitter and you want
something else then that's fine as well
I'm also frequently on Instagram
Facebook so I do have a snapchat but I
don't think that's really the place to
get coding advice from so not really on
the that often
alright so let me go back to this and
this will probably be the last see what
time it is
so I'll do one more Pomodoro session of
doing some of the work on this site and
then then I'll try to get through as
many questions in the live chat as I can
let me see let me take I'm going to do a
few more questions there at the top of
the live chat because I'm afraid that
they'll they'll get pushed off if I if I
don't look at them now so also if if I
don't answer your question in the live
chat I'm sorry please put it in the
comments for this video or message me on
some other social media platform and
I'll get to your question because I
really do and answer all your questions
I just don't always have time in in
during the stream me ass how did you
work through that site Ming knew okay
that must have been must be in regard to
the that first site that I showed you
all this this site yeah it did it took
me a long time to work through that when
I was new it was crazy I actually didn't
even have a computer for the first
couple of days that I worked which was
insane because like I'm a web developer
how what am I going to do without a
computer so once I did get a computer
then I just I started to look through it
all and I just kept looking at the code
I just inspected it in dev tools and
kept looking and just messing around and
seeing how far I could push it and after
a lot of trial and error of doing it
like that then I
finally got to I got it to what it is
now
so it did it took a long time and you
know the it was it was frustrating it
was a bit of a mess but I really really
wanted to prove myself and so I I did it
it worked and my my boss gave me a ton
of time to do it so it was really cool
about since I was new just really gave
me a lot of freedom and time to figure
things up but anyway yeah it was it
wasn't exactly fun in terms of the
workflow but it was kind of cool just to
see how far I could take a platform that
was obviously outdated alright so I
think I got far enough down on the chat
that I won't lose too much and now I can
I can do some of this so let's see I
guess we can just start into a homepage
now
and let me bring over where'd I put it
got a lot of windows open sorry need to
find where I put the example oh I see
that it logged me out automatically so
that's another wonderful thing about
this site is that you frequently get
logged out you can't use the back button
if you try to use the back button it
gives you an error sometimes you can use
it but a lot of times like it just gives
you an error message so anyway alright
so this is what we're going off of like
I said I don't have to go with this so
just for the basic layout that I think I
am gonna keep no matter what is you know
I definitely want this side panel I may
even go with and always open side panel
at least for desktop and the top bar I
don't think I'm gonna do this that says
you know says the name I probably could
do it since everyone yeah I'm not I'm
not gonna try to do this so it's not
gonna say people's name so that was kind
of a fun little feature but definitely
not you not at all necessary alright so
first things first let's just get this
base layout of the header nav and then
we'll throw in a footer I don't have one
here but we may as well throw in a
footer and that'll be a nice start
alright so let's go to the code here and
that's also on my my other screen let me
bring it over on this screen so you all
can see what I'm seeing I'm gonna close
in the side here and my my code editor I
just kind of closed off the the file the
pain that has all the files in there
just to gain us some space alright so
I'm gonna kind of scroll through this
just to see if there's anything that I
really need to worry about
so this usage section seems kind of
important so let's just check this out
before we do anything okay so seem to be
provided
okay so it looks like I need a theme and
for the theme provider it's an app just
so
hmm
all right I'm not if someone has used
material UI before let me know about
this but this is what I think it's
saying it seems like it's basically
saying I need to have any time I use one
of the components from there I need to
import this this Mui theme provider so
can I get away with just importing this
in my app j/s or do it will I actually
need to import this in every like can I
just wrap app in this or what I mean
potentially like could I go out to the
index jas and wrap app inside of this so
I'm gonna I actually want to go back to
the page that has the examples because
that'll be better to get the visual so
let's see if it if it explains it more
Wow
I guess it does
all right so that's a while they're
getting started page is really like
getting started like what is a single
page application right
is this the one that says a virgin one
is coming
why don't we just use this version
about that as anyone tried the next the
new version I mean if if they're about
to come out with version 1 why are we
building it with the earlier version
that's just a rhetorical question for me
it's not it's not your father this is my
fault
well I should have thought about this
yeah let's do that let's let's use this
version so material UI next let's do
that
where's my yeah okay so we're gonna do
yarn remove I think removers is what you
say a material
all right that's important actually I'm
kind of glad I did this because if
you're using yarn you want to do yarn
remove it's not a good idea to go in
here into your package.json and actually
like delete something from this it's
better to use yarn the reason being when
you do yarn remove it'll update your
yarn lock file you don't want to mess
with that manually so always remember to
do this through either you are an add or
remove and it'll just be it'll work out
better like that all right so now we
want to do yarn add and we're gonna use
material you I and next all right so
that's cool
III really I like the idea of using the
latest stuff anyway I think that's
better
okay
all right so now that we're through with
that
let's hear I con all right let's install
the icons as well so yarn add material
UI is a oops material you icons
okay
all right so now this actually this
looks like exactly the same thing that
was on the github documentation so not
really telling me much
all right I'm gonna I did look at the
chat again I could see you over like hey
you gotta read haha alright so let me
let me read at least the bottom of this
chat again because okay so bill says the
Mui theme provider is only a tap j/s
awesome ok so just that really cool
Aaron s are you familiar with Redux not
yet but I am learning it I will be
learning it soon and bill so later on
I'd wrap it even around the react router
ok that's good to know thank you
oh man
rich buses there are some missing
components in material I've e1 ok I
think I'm gonna deal with that I think
I'm ok with the missing components and
work around that if we need to build out
some components on our own
I'm I'm kind of I'm cool with that this
is not read yeah i wasn't reading the
chat ok cool sebastian linked up he put
in a link in the chat about which
components are actually supported so
thank you for that i'll check that out
that's the best in says this will suck
for him haha ok Aaron says he's lying
you can remove dependencies from
package.json you just need to run yarn
again after you do it ok good to know
yeah I am that's cool
you can run yarn again so if what I was
saying about yarn and not editing
package.json is not exactly true so it
you just have to run yarn again so if
you used to
I guess it would be the same way if
you're using regular NPM like you can
remove it from package.json but it's not
actually gonna be removed until you run
it again so yeah forget what I just said
thanks thanks for calling me out on that
errand so as long just remember if you
don't use yarn remove and you edit the
package.json directly run yarn again
all of us is not a good idea to use an
alpha version of a framework yeah
actually Sebastian the link you sent for
some reason is coming up with a blank
page for me so off to check that out
later
this is the one
all right it doesn't say all right at
this point I just want to build
something so if I have to switch back to
the other one it should be fine because
it seems like the the the mark up at
least is somewhat similar I mean at
least this part is similar so the first
part that I need to do will be similar
so let's just do that let's look at let
make this a bit bigger as you all can
see
how it would rest I tried to commit this
and I didn't add the files first all
right cool
get committed there we go
all right so where's our app there it is
let me see I actually don't want this on
my I want to put this at the level of
the index I'm gonna copy this and put
this in here
and we're gonna wrap this
all right cool
so no errors great and then just double
check and make sure I didn't miss
something great okay good let's
layouts
yeah I don't really want I just want
components
there than that of
okay
that's what I need terminology is a
little bit different than than a
materialized framework so I've to get
used to that but let's check out what we
need to do here we need to import quite
a bit
we're saying it but more astonishing
okay I say terrible idea to use alpha
version unless your contributor alright
so I'm getting a lot of a lot of advice
about not using the Alpha in production
all right all right you all have
convinced me I'll switch it back
I'm not going to switch it back right
now because you've already seen me
switch it back and forth a couple of
times so I will switch it back later on
today so you guys you will you all that
are giving me advice I totally
understand what you're saying and you
have convinced me but it did it felt a
little bit like I don't know like when
you're a kid and you're about to do
something that's probably pretty
dangerous and like maybe your friends or
your parents or somebody you're saying
like no no you don't want to do that
don't do it so I like I guess I was
being silly and wanted to live
dangerously alright so I guess I should
just double-check really quickly to make
sure that the let's make sure that
everything is the same in terms of
markup since if I'm going to switch it
No all right
and then you notice MF okay four minutes
before I'm going to stop so let's try to
do something that's for when let's
import this at bar and
let's get rid of some of this stuff
and then what we call this pepper
probably I'm guessing that some of this
isn't going to work since these icons I
think are different for the newer
version but might be able to at least
see something nope
Oh
see
I thought it said that the icons were
different I should double-check before I
remove these icons
because it doesn't say anything about
the icons so maybe I don't need to worry
about it so maybe I can remove it safely
oops is it not I thought it was that's
what it was called so double check that
whoa it's here you okay
I guess it's not I didn't have to put
that in when I was removing it
okay so John says and that says living
on the edge Jessie's mantra yeah I'm in
a unique position I feel like to where I
have like nearly complete freedom to
pick what tools I want to use to build
sites with and I don't think I'll always
have that so I kind of like to take
advantage of it to try a lot of new
things so that way it's good like a
learning opportunity I don't want to
build things the same way every single
time all right now we're going to add
this back in
okay wonderful let's see if this work
still not working
what am I missing
Adler okay
so we have this header
alright it's giving me a header that has
a height of zero what did I do wrong
okay Aaron says try restarting the
server that's a good idea
let's give it a restart see what happens
it's gonna be kind of rough all right
awesome thank you so much Aaron that was
great advice it's gonna be a little bit
rough starting out because this is a new
framework for me I mean I'm I'm really
familiar with material design but in
terms of this particular framework I
have no experience with so I apologize
for the slow start here but I'm sure
once I get the hang of it it'll be nice
it'll be a lot nicer than trying to make
all the jQuery stuff work with with
react so awesome so that's cool that
works and that's probably yep my time is
up
so anyway if you are just here to watch
me do my thing on the screen and set
things up then you can you safely leave
now because I'm done with that part of
it now I'm gonna go through the live
chat and try to answer as many questions
as I can before I end I would like to
end this around 4 and that'll be a 2
hour 2 hour livestream which i think is
plenty plenty long in terms of extremes
so anyway so if you did watch and you
need to go now you're not worried about
the you know the question answer session
thank you so much for watching and
thanks for all your help and as I said
earlier feel free to ask me any
questions on any social media stuff
or in the YouTube comments and I'll be
happy to you know get back to you as
soon as I can I definitely don't
consider myself an expert but if you
still want my advice in spite of that
I'm happy to give it now for everyone
that can stick around I'm going to
answer some questions I'm going way up
to the the top of the live chat
so I a lot of the chat is now not
available to me anymore but basically
everything from around 2:30 p.m. Eastern
Time on is still available for me right
now so I'm gonna just start there and go
down if I didn't get to your question
cuz let's say I got pushed off the page
I'm really sorry please ask me again in
some other forum either in another live
chat or in any any social media stuff
I've actually I've even had people find
my email address and email me so that's
cool too if you want to do that I no one
has yet found my phone number and called
me so I'm waiting I'm sure it'll happen
one day
okay so nag nag Indra asks I am new what
kind of project will you do today how
long does it take
XANA gave a nice explanation saying I'm
refactoring a very old static site and
it's probably going to take about three
weeks so yeah I'm gonna stream probably
around two hours every weekday for the
next three weeks or so and I I expect
that's what it'll take
if I decide to add some extra features
then you know might take longer than
that but I'm thinking just keeping it
with the base features that it has right
now I'm guessing about three weeks and
that's including like I realize there's
probably gonna be times when I can't
work on this um enough to spend time and
meetings and things like that I know I
have some I have to do some interviews
we're interviewing for a web developer
job here I have some interview scheduled
coming up and so there's going to be a
lot of other stuff I have to do so if I
were dedicating all the time to this I
probably could do it in less than three
weeks and then there's also the
additional you know added extra time in
that I'm using create react app instead
of next which I'm not as familiar with
and now I'm using material UI instead of
materialized so I'm gonna have to learn
some things as I go also going to
attempt to use tests
and Lucas says what's up what's up Lucas
thanks for joining us
Emilio asks does anybody know what this
site is going to do like general like
crud it's it's not really gonna like do
a ton in terms of like interactivity
right now the it's just gonna have a
basic contact form and I'm not a contact
form a project submission form that is
gonna have a file upload but I'm not
creating a database for that information
at least I don't plan on it now it might
be cool to do but we'll see how it goes
but basically that info is going to go
to using an API a REST API it's going to
go to our project management system
which is rike so that's the plan if I
have time it would kind of be cool to
hook up some sort of database to this
just to have like another place to back
things up right now we have the problem
that occasionally the files won't go to
R I can upload files through the API to
write but occasionally it won't work
and so it'll come through in the email
or the file name but the actual file
will never make its way into write so it
might not be a bad idea to have another
place where I store those so we will be
going over how to do file uploads and
node which that'll be cool Umberto's
says I understood it to be like a
service desk that's ticketing system
yeah actually it's exactly like that
umberto that's a good way to explain it
abhishek says i just started studying
react from full-stack react book is
completing the book with examples enough
for getting my first job effects as says
no dustin says try and see how it goes
so I would say it really depends like
getting your first job is going to
depend on a lot of different things so
it's hard to say whether or not
completing you know one book or one
course is going to be enough basically
to get a job all you have to do is
convince someone to hire you so that it
helps if you have experience in a good
portfolio but really you don't you don't
necessarily need that so the more you
can do to build up your portfolio then
the better chance you'll have it getting
a job so if if you're learning a lot
with this book and you're doing a lot of
things then yeah maybe you could get a
job with that I'm not really familiar
with the book so I can't say I can't
speak like to the content of that book
specifically but I do get similar
questions occasionally and you know my
answer is just you know you you can try
to get a job at any point you might get
it because you know it really all you
have to do is convince somebody that you
can do the job so for some people you
know they take they study for a really
long time before they get a job other
people a few months and they get a job
and then they have to learn a lot on the
job but I wouldn't say like don't feel
like you have to complete so many things
before you can start looking for a job
look for a job while you're learning and
if you get it wonderful if not keep
learning and keep trying in this
industry it's not like you need a
certain type of certification which i
think is really cool so but I would say
as you're going through those examples
build up your portfolio actually build
do side projects do some freelance stuff
do wood
you can because that's really important
to be able to prove that you can do the
work the bill says I went back and
listened to the first twenty five
minutes of the stream
I missed that four times speed caught
caught up and the speed differs charring
at first I must talk slow enough that
that's possible to understand me at four
times speed I never thought about doing
that that's pretty cool max you may ask
about the black github so let me show
you my github so the background is black
so yeah
I kind of don't want to go into again
how I got this to work because I've done
it a few times before in previous videos
but basically there's a github dark
theme so if you do a search for github
dark you should be able to find all the
instructions to do it maybe one day I'll
do a video like showing how to do it
since a lot of people ask me about it
but for now like check out github dark
it looks like there's there's been some
a bit of discussion about women
programmers and men programmers and
stuff so I don't know that if I want to
read out this whole discussion in the
live chat
yeah I think I'll probably just get a
skip it I don't want to like trigger
anybody if you know you came here
looking for reactant instead you get a
debate on you know gender and coding and
stuff so so I'm gonna say I'm just
letting you know everybody involved in
that discussion I'm not gonna read out
the comments not that it's not a good
thing to talk about I just don't want to
I don't want this stream to get into
like debatable topics I just would like
it to be a calm place I'd be check ass
okay so if I complete the free code camp
react challenges then so then can you
get a job so I mean I think my answer
from before or still suffice is to this
to just you know you can get a job when
you get to the point where you can
convince people you can do the work and
it convinced them to hire you
so yes free code camp will help you get
to that point but it's not a guarantee
so just you know you got to do whatever
you can to increase your skills you know
and try to network to there's other
things besides just the programming that
can help you get a job being able to
network you know having a presence
online by your social media and your
projects your portfolio that all those
things are important
okay bill says great about a create
react app is built in the Jeff slash
enzyme support okay so for testing I
should probably start looking into jest
then is that I think that's which would
bill say in here since create react app
already has has that so that's good to
know I wasn't exactly sure what testing
framework I should start with
all right
okay Santa said John now that would be
oh it's John said to make make your own
in terms of CSS frameworks make your own
less bulk that would be really cool I do
really want to do that one day to make
my own framework that basically would
fit everything that we use at the
University for our brand standards and
our style guide and make a framework
that other like if we hire people to
build websites that they can just use
that or if other departments end up
having developers that they can use that
so that that is actually the end goal
for me at some point if I can just build
off of work other people have done
though that would be cool as well I know
it would be more lightweight if I did it
myself but I mean there's there's a lot
of things that I could just build on
that other people have done that I don't
necessarily need to redo myself and then
Jana
kind of rightly says that would be ideal
but he only gave it three weeks so yeah
that's that's kind of the thing I'm not
worried about actually building the UI
but in terms of then taking what I've
built custom from scratch and then
testing it in all different browsers and
devices and screen sizes like that's the
part that I think is the most difficult
when you're trying to build like a CSS
framework or something from scratch is
that these frameworks that are already
there so many people are using them that
a lot of those issues have already come
up you know from their use and so
they've you know they've dealt with
issues that I wouldn't even you know
know about when I so it's just you know
yes it is a little bit more you know
possibly a little bloated but you get
the benefit of having all the basically
all these testers you know for free that
did you have all their experience and
all the issues that they've worked
through so I'll probably end up doing
some sort of custom framework but it'll
definitely be built off of someone
else's potentially I might just end up
trying to contribute to one of the
material design react frameworks out
there
and that might be better than trying to
do my own just in general for the for
the entire community it might be better
to not make a new one and instead just
try to make an existing one even better
all right let me look through here let's
say I'm going back through there there
were a lot of different suggestions for
for frame where CSS frameworks and stuff
so I really appreciate all the all the
suggestions
all right so Ryan asks do you use the
Pomodoro Technique when you are working
or just during livestreams to answer
questions so I think I actually
mentioned this earlier so maybe you'd
asked that question before I said it but
yeah I do use the Pomodoro Technique
when I'm working and I find it helpful I
should actually add that to the list of
stuff that I'm going to do videos on
because I've gotten some questions on
that too I think that would be useful
just to go over the Pao is that two tuna
on a switch back end are you using I
mean this is this is going to be node
everything's going to be in node and in
terms of like their terms of databases
there's going to be no database prop
probably no database we'll see we'll see
how it goes but yeah this is going to be
reacting no jazz okay about about an
hour ago
cat has I guess how long this is going
to be because it was already 9 p.m. in
Europe so I guess it's a little late for
that question but usually the streams
are around 2 hours long
like kayo asks will you make the source
code available yes it actually is
available now on github it's public
it'll be there so you can check it out
whenever you want
okay so I got some comments about the
inject tap event plugin and how to
initialize that so cool it says the
drawer component doesn't work without it
so that explains why the drawer
component wasn't working I suppose so
thank you for that
Nathaniel says I do not know how to use
react however I'll be learning soon
maybe after I'll do some pull requests
that sounds awesome yeah definitely let
me know if you need any help at
everything with with learning react and
then that'd be really cool
vk3 ask someone from Macedonia smiley
with a smiley face anybody from
Macedonia around Vitor says it's love
from Portugal awesome thanks for thanks
for watching
Jack Bennett asks what's a good language
to learn I would say JavaScript but I'm
biased because that's what I mostly use
it entirely depends on what you want to
do so if you want to do web development
then learn JavaScript that's your best
you'll you're for sure going to use
JavaScript at some point if you're a web
developer you may end up using other
languages as well but you wouldn't have
to you can build pretty much whatever
you want on the web with just JavaScript
Nathaniel asked any resources you'd
recommend for learning react the react
documentation like the official
documentation is great if you want to
spend money you'd acity has a react
course right now that I'm doing and I'm
pretty impressed with it so far
free code campus good free resources
code Academy has a free course so I
would check those ones out and then
there's a lot of YouTube videos about it
as well
Maximus is from France awesome I love
hearing where everybody's from it it
does it never gets old to hear
everybody's from it's always really cool
every time to hear people from all over
the world that are joining in
michael says hey just starting up a
react project for myself project myself
creating a ride share app for a
university that also records co2
statistics per ride and an aggregate
that sounds really really cool so
Michael if you're still watching I know
that comment was from a while ago if
you're still watching I'd love to see
that so if you could put either in the
live chat or send me a message on
Twitter or something like if you have a
link to the github github repo for that
that would be really cool I'd love to
see that Shahriyar from Bangladesh
awesome
Raunak says it's 1:00 a.m. here heiped
awesome
on a new rug says I'm from India awesome
things going on cool he's just saying
that Gregg says what I would love to see
you do Trello board when you're all set
up yeah I'm gonna make the Trello board
public and then I'll put a link in the
video description so I'll have the link
in all the descriptions for the videos
when I'm working on this so my one of my
co-workers is logged into the Franciscan
University YouTube channel and he
occasionally types in silly things into
the chat so this time he's typing once I
did get a computer huh
Raunak says how do you plan what to do
first
setting up routing directory structure
or go feature-wise in a project I have
to think about it a little bit to think
about how I've done it before because
I'm often I usually don't get a chance
to have like a nice planning period
occasionally like I'm just pulled into
projects sometimes that are it's not
exactly from scratch so I don't like it
kind of does it depends on what the
project is
sorry I can't my brains just like no not
working right now I just can't think of
how I normally do that and so I'll have
to think more about that and get back to
you I would say like in big picture I
definitely think about features but then
when I actually get down to it I go more
by like structure so like you know pages
at a time like get the main page layout
and then each page so I guess that would
be that's kind of how I go about it
ah rich rich bob says use angular
material I assume your big fun
so you're joking they're not sure that
would work this pressing amazing says
please can you continue this live or
maybe record it even if you have to
voiceover later I'll probably do some
live streaming like in the mornings
where I don't really give commentary and
I just work when I do those I actually I
do them on my own channel so that I
don't take up the free code camp channel
all day so if you're interested in that
if you follow my or subscribe to my
channel on YouTube then you'll get a
notification when I do that I also
usually post on Twitter when I do it too
so either way if you see my Twitter
notification or whatever you know they
know you might be able to see more more
of the project
alright man there's so much in the live
chat I'm really I kind of think there's
no way I'm going to get through every
question so I'm really sorry about that
let's see
hey evil that's gone I just saw Eva said
hey Jessie what you're doing so and John
John B says what are you building so
yeah I'm building it react a pretty
simple react site you bucha says there's
nothing wrong with using a framework
that's on the bleeding edge alright
thanks you do that I mean yeah it's
probably a good idea not to use it in a
project that I really need to do for
work maybe in a side project I'll try
like the really bleeding edge stuff
Aaron says programming always starts off
slow yeah that's true
Luka says if anything you'll be
encouraged to contribute to the project
yeah that's that's actually good idea so
he's saying if you use something that's
bleeding edge you know like alpha
version or something of a framework then
you'll have a lot of encouragement to
contribute because you I mean you're
likely gonna see a lot of bugs and
things so I never thought about that but
that is a good point
nobody says slow is cool for us
beginners even because of you I will
start learning react oh that's cool
that's really cool
ya know d let me let me know how it's
going with learning react and if I can
help with anything I'm happy to help
Aaron says keep on rockin Jesse cool
thanks
Enoch score says I'm too late again oh
sorry sorry you're late you can check
the recording I'll probably do tomorrow
I'm actually going to do a different
time so maybe it might be better for
some people I think I'm gonna have to do
stream in the morning because I have a
meeting at 2:00 p.m. Eastern tomorrow
uh-huh Bobby Marvin did you really try
to post my my phone number in the live
chat you didn't push the last two that's
actually my I think that is my work
number I'll have to look it up because I
don't remember my work I actually don't
know my work phone number yeah Marvin I
think that is my work number so I kept
thinking people would get my cell phone
number cuz that's out there as well but
yeah you found it I didn't even think
about that that obviously my work number
is probably online but my cell number is
online as well because when I was
freelancing I use that as my business
number so anyway if anybody really
really wants to call me I just I never
answer I let everything go to voicemail
so if you leave a message I'll get it I
just get so many like calls from like
spam calls that I just never answered my
phone anymore baby says hello new here
just wanted to say thanks for doing this
when is the next time you'll be doing
this welcome and you're welcome thanks
for for watching the next time will be
tomorrow - probably tomorrow morning
augusten says thanks for coding late it
was good when is the next session so
yeah the same thing probably tomorrow
morning John B says how long have you
been using react just this year so I
probably started building and react in
the spring of this year somewhere around
there so not not actually that long I
think some point last year I tried to do
like a hello world app and react but so
I don't really count that because that
wasn't really seriously trying to learn
Aaron says is there a way I could do a
stream on free code camp I've been
programming for 18 years and love to
teach yeah I think that's possible
it's not really my call you would need
to ask Quincy or or get ahold of Bo
so check probably on Twitter it might be
the best way to get ahold of Quincy so
or you can just tweet at free code camp
so he manages both the accounts so check
out the free code camp Twitter and maybe
send a message and say like hey you know
I was checking out Jesse stream I'd like
to do something like that and he might
be open to it
so I can't really guarantee anything but
that would be really cool John says is
it possible to make the final production
JavaScript and CSS assets safe
separately for each page in a website
even though there are many shared
components templating etc yeah I suppose
suppose so maybe I'm sure maybe if
there's some other people in the
watching right now that have more
experience with that you could explain
it in a better way
Martin says is finishing my free code
camp friend certificate enough to get
first job I'm almost done I have CS
degree already but that hasn't been
enough
honestly Martin if you have a CS degree
and you're gonna do the free code camp
certificate I mean you're in a good
place right there because you know
you're gonna have the best of both
worlds in terms of you know you have the
kind of online and do-it-yourself
learning and you have the degree so
you're gonna have an advantage in count
of those old-school companies that still
really value a degree so I would say
yeah go for it and it sometimes it can
take a long time to get a job I know
when I was looking for work after I
finished college it took me a long time
and the jobs that I eventually got were
not really great jobs and then whenever
I quit my I whenever I quit teaching I
used to be a teacher I was looking for
work it took me a while to find work too
and I eventually basically just did
freelance work actually hold on my wife
is calling so she's about to be on the
stream hello hey I was gonna leave maybe
around 5:30 is that is that cool okay
okay okay
okay sorry about that but I want this to
be realistic about how my normal day is
and sometimes I get phone calls
okay so DJ says it could be enough to
just get the certificate from free code
camp to get a job from personal
experience I was able to get one without
a CS degree after doing the front-end
certificate so that's really cool so so
DJ saying they were able to get a job
with without a CS degree with just the
front-end free code camp certificate so
that's really awesome congratulations on
that that's that's great and it looks
like you are given some great advice to
Martin there in the live chat so thanks
for that and yeah Martin as well some
people are talking about like LinkedIn
and different social media Martin if you
want to follow me on some social media
stuff and your that might help like
expand your network a bit like on
LinkedIn and if you want to like put out
a tweet or something saying that you're
looking for work I'll be happy to
retweet you I don't have a ton of
followers on Twitter but most of the
people that fall in the are in you know
in tech so it would be good you know
good get those tweets up to get to get
it out to people who might actually be
able to hire you or pass it along to
somebody
okay cool bill and Aaron are both saying
yes use Jess for the testing framework
cool
all right Aaron says I made my own CSS
framework for hired comm that's really
cool
Aaron if you're still with us in the
chat how how long did it take you to
make the CSS framework and was it was it
a difficult process I'm really
interested in in that you know because
as I said earlier I'd like to at some
point
jonbi says should I apply if an employer
wants five plus years experience when I
only have two years of experience I
would do it I've applied for jobs where
I didn't have the experience that they
wanted because you never know usually
when people put out job descriptions
that's like best-case scenario of what
they want but they're willing to take
less than that so and if they don't get
anybody that meets those requirements
sometimes they're more willing to take
less than that so it's worth a shot as
long as the application process isn't
like really difficult then it might be a
waste of your time but if it's a pretty
simple application process and it only
take you in a few minutes or so then I
say go for it
Martin says I'm already over a year past
graduating I should already have a job
yeah I mean it can be really tough I
would say like I mean finding a job I
don't know if I'd say like you know you
should or shouldn't already have a job
like it just all depends like your
location in the job market there there's
a lot of factors that go into how easy
or difficult it is to get a job so don't
get too down on yourself just keep at it
keep trying you may have to take a job
just that you don't really want just to
pay the bills there's no there's nothing
wrong with that or like maybe you might
want to take a job that is paying you a
lot less than you probably you know
would want but it'll get you good
experience to get the job that you want
so I mean there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of different factors that
go into that but I'd say just keep
working keep doing side projects if you
can or freelance work do anything you
can to build up your portfolio and keep
applying you know keep applying to a lot
a lot of places and even if you're not
exactly qualified you know that's that's
the only way I mean at some point it's
probably going to work out there's a lot
of jobs out there so you just got to
keep at it
Wesley says try to take advice serious
and dare to take risks in life and you
will succeed and almost everything you
put effort into and thanks for that
Wesley yeah I mean definitely uh you
know when you're given advice by people
especially people that have you know
kind of been in they've been there and
they've gone through that like yeah I
try to learn how you can and yeah taking
risk I mean sometimes it does say that
it takes going out on a limb like I put
my job and ended up on freelance and it
was really like I wasn't sure how things
were gonna go you know was I gonna be
able to pay the bills and stuff and it
led me to where I am now
you know after it took a couple years
you know a couple of years of you know
wasn't always easy it was difficult but
you know I kept at it and now I'm I'm
you know I have a job where I'm happy
I'm doing what I really like I make
enough to pay the bills so yeah keep at
it
thanks for that Wesley
Martin Martin says actually work Martin
said something that's a bit negative
towards Wesley's comment I'm not gonna
read it out but Martin I will say I mean
if you're gonna come on here and ask for
advice and people are gonna give you
advice like you really probably
shouldn't be negative at them you know
like they don't owe you any advice
they're just kind of trying to do it out
of the kindness of their own heart so if
you don't think the advice is good just
don't take it but I don't think it's
really it's really right to be so
critical of someone who's just trying to
help you out and doesn't really owe you
anything
also I try to we try to keep the live
chat a place where like we're very like
non critical of of things like I'm all
up for a debate about you know various
frameworks and tools and stuff but I
don't want any like any like
name-calling or like derogatory things
being said so you know let's try to keep
this a positive place where people can
feel free to you know express themselves
here give advice ask for advice and
things so you know just you know every
for everyone you know just keep that in
mind
yeah I'm gonna read this one out here
Martin says here I am getting berated by
people who actually got jobs doing the
same exact things I've tried when I was
unlucky and didn't I mean I would say
like I mean I I just read all the
comments there Martin so I'm not sure
what you mean by being berated
everybody's just giving you advice so I
know it must be frustrating not to get a
job but you know the idea I mean the
idea that you're just unlucky and didn't
get jobs implies that they got jobs
because they were lucky I don't think
luck has anything to do with it getting
a job is based on you know your skills
your effort who you know you know your
connections so I mean the people in here
you know most likely worked really hard
it's not easy so I mean I wouldn't you
know don't don't belittle that and don't
try to boil it down to like luck or
something like you're just gonna get
that's not gonna be a helpful outlook
you know because then you're like just
turn that into something more creative I
know it's easier said than done but if
you see people around you getting jobs
you know you could take it you know two
ways or more but you know one way you
could take it is you know kind of
getting down on yourself saying like
what's wrong with me that I can't get a
job another way you could take it is
like motivation like hey like it's
happening for them it's gonna happen for
me like I'm gonna work hard I'm gonna
ask them for advice see what they did
so anyway I'm gonna skip through
I'm gonna skip through some of that
because the the the debate is kind of
getting a little heated there
yeah it looks like Martin's kind of
still going on with this lucky stuff I
will say this like Martin there's no
such thing as luck man I mean I'm like
there-there is that like Chet it's it's
it's not like it's not like these people
have some good luck charm to get jobs
it's you know there there are steps you
take right to do to get job and you keep
working at it will some people fail it's
possible yes some people will probably
fail and not get jobs there are people
without jobs it happens but I don't
really think it's right to say that all
these people in here that have jobs just
got lucky
I mean that's that's not it's not the
case you know you have to do all the
work and put in all the effort and even
then sometimes it's not enough but that
doesn't mean that these people are just
lucky and didn't put in the work and it
doesn't mean that they didn't you know
in a sense earn what they have so I know
you're really frustrated on that but
yeah just not I'm not like in all the
the negativity because once again you
know everybody on here is really trying
to help and you you ask for the help and
they're just only what you asked them to
do
um let's see Nathaniel said I'd
appreciate if you send me some links to
react resources on free code camp forums
I will moderate on the forums so you
should be able to find my profile easily
from the team list I'll see I actually
want to do a video on that as and so
maybe I'll I might do a video on that if
I get a chance soon so um I don't know
if I'll get a chance to just put them on
there if you the best thing to do would
would be either put it as a comment on
this video or send it to me and unlike
Twitter basically that same request so I
don't forget about it and then I'll try
to do it one asked about the project
being in github it is it's in github now
but there's not really much to it
she vomits how is angular vs. react in
terms of performance Co I'm not really
sure I can answer that because I'm not
nearly as familiar with angular as I am
with react all I can say is that I've
been very happy with react so far what
I'm using it but that's not really
enough to answer that question properly
so I apologize but I I'm not going to
try to you know talk through an answer
when I I'm really just not confident in
my knowledge of angular to give a good
answer
Victor us can javascript be used for
making simple offline applications - I
often have the idea an idea for a tiny
thing I want to make and from Denmark
yeah you can you can build offline
applications with JavaScript so if
you're like with react you can build web
apps but you can also build apps that
will work on a desktop you can build
apps that will run on on mobile phones
so JavaScript is very versatile in terms
of what it can do
Evos says in regard to the performance
issue between react and angular says I
think a lot of the performance talks can
be skipped the performance only really
matters when you need fast rendering
application I'm talking over 60 frames
per second okay so that's that's cool
perspective there yeah and that's
probably true I mean really it depends
on what you're doing but for most sites
and web apps the difference between one
framework another in terms of
performance probably won't even be
noticeable to the average user it like I
said depending on what you're doing
it may not be noticeable
all right I'm kind of trying to skip
through okay I miss Santa saying goodbye
I always miss her saying goodbyes
let's see I'm going to try to skip
through a lot of this stuff and
[Music]
just get to some questions Martinez who
says it's really be motivating to watch
the stream like this where everybody
already has a job as jobs or internships
why would you be watching this if you
are you're a pro right programming job
actually there are a lot of people that
don't have jobs yet they watch this and
I've already had at least two people
that started watching when they didn't
have a job and then have gotten jobs
since then so it's definitely a mix a
lot of the people that are actually
contributing to the chat do have jobs
and that's so that's why probably seems
like most people have the jobs but it
just so happens the people of jobs
usually have the most experience so
they're able to contribute the most in
the live chat but definitely I
definitely do have a mix of people and
we have people of a variety of Ages all
over the world and are all skill levels
- I frequently have people come on here
and say like hey I just literally I've
had people say I just started learning
to programming yesterday so definitely
different you know all different people
for instance Victor just writes thank
you guys just getting started with
coding and I've heard a lot of good
about JavaScript will probably keep
going down that route awesome
that sounds good Victor and uh you know
if you need any help with that or
anything you run in any trouble with
like just let me know be happy to help
if I can
oh man she oh I'm said it's a 1:45 a.m.
in India and that was that was a little
while ago so getting pretty late so
everybody from India over there that's
for watching really late thanks for
staying up and watching Martin says I
have almost nothing on my github
- but I'm finishing the free code camp
certificate right now which is something
yeah actually I definitely Martin I
definitely recommend trying to fill out
your github profile as much as you can
because like I know sometimes like when
we're hiring people here and I have to
look through resumes if someone has a
github profile
I'm way more interested automatically
and then I check their profile and if
they have they're actually using and
they have stuff on there that's a big
plus to me I'm always nervous when
somebody applies and they don't give me
their github profile I usually try to
look it up anyway and if I can't find it
I wonder like what but what are they
doing you know where's all their code at
it doesn't automatically mean that they
don't know what they're doing but it's
just like I I can't see what they're
doing so that's that's a big thing and
I've actually heard other people who
hire a lot say like if you have a get up
profile you're automatically on the top
of the pile if you have an active you
know github profile and stuff on there
so definitely you try to get as much on
there as you can and you know side
projects if you're doing freelance work
you know I would try to put it like in
your contracts that that your all your
code is yours and you're allowed to put
it on github and things like that so
that you can get that stuff on there
Martin saying all my projects look bad
yeah Martin I would say it's better to
have something on there than not if a
person is hiring they're gonna look at
like when I look at somebody's get a
profile like if I'm thinking about you
know doing an interview or hiring them I
don't usually get stuck on like the
final product like I want to see the
process so even if the end product
doesn't look that good if I can go back
and see the the process of you know them
actually kind of improving things and if
I could see like their later projects
are actually getting better then that at
least shows me that they're teaching
themselves and picking up new things and
that's really important to me I would
rather hire somebody who shows the
ability to teach themselves new things
you know quickly and improve upon their
work then somebody who's like already
knows everything right because it even
if you know everything now a year from
now you know there's gonna be new stuff
and it's not going to be you know you're
not gonna be at the top of the game
anymore but somebody who has that
ability to rapidly teach themselves new
things and improve they're always going
to be on top of things so so I would say
I mean you know even if you're not
entirely satisfied with the projects it
still gives people an idea of your your
thought process you know to read your
commit messages you know and see what's
what's going on now you know and how you
work that's that's important
Blake says what is Jesse's channel on
the link to my channel my youtube
channel is in the description to this
video is it Jesse it might be Jesse why
go
Jesse Weigel 29 maybe I don't remember
what the the thing is but it's in the
description
Nathaniel says I'm applying to colleges
to get a CS degree in the next four to
six years wish me luck yeah good luck
Oh Blake asks what is localhost 3000
server yeah so I guess you're talking
about like this up here the localhost
when I run the server locally to work on
my site that's what it is it's just a
local server port 3000
Martin's asking about github and like
how to do things free code camp actually
has a video series on github and then
Udacity has a free course on git and
github I definitely recommend those
those will be a great introduction to
using git and contributing on github
because that's that's really important a
lot of places want people who know how
to use git and so that'd be really kind
of a plus to be able to put on your
resume
okay it looks like Martin left so
probably Martin didn't hear some of
those later suggestions that I gave
which that's kind of stinks but maybe
he'll watch the the recording alright
let me scroll down I gather this videos
already going on way longer than I
expected so I'm gonna kind of skip a lot
of the comments and just try to go to
the questions now
Dominic asks what's the value of using
react versus just HTML CSS and
JavaScript I don't know I don't know let
me see if somebody else answered okay it
looks like bill answered I remembered
this time to check component base
reloading is a major value not having to
refresh the entire Dom when data updates
yes yes
Dominic gasps is there any value and
learning react over the dotnet framework
it just depends on I guess what you want
to work on I I don't really enjoy
working with the dotnet framework when I
have had to work on it now usually I've
had to work on like really old things
that use dotnet so maybe that's why I
didn't enjoy it as much so it just
depends on what you want to do you know
if you want to stick with all JavaScript
stuff then learn react if you want to be
you know learn other stuff then you
learn net you know if you if you really
want to work at a place that uses dotnet
and then learned on that
Scottie says our tutorial projects good
for github if you don't have anything
then yeah for sure just it's better it's
better to have something than nothing I
think a tutorial project at the very
least shows that you are learning on
your own and and that's that's important
that's better than not having anything
or just not having a lot let's see John
B asks Jessie do you think it's
important to study up on data structures
for interviews I don't really know I
guess it kind of depends on where you're
interviewing at what the position is and
you know try to figure out as much as
you can about the interviews I think if
you go on glassdoor.com people will post
interview questions that they've gotten
there so if you can research and see
like you'll probably get a good idea
about what questions people have been
asked and what's most important to study
up on
Scottie says should the new guys fear
the whiteboard questions I don't know
don't be afraid to whiteboard question I
mean if you if you do your or your you
know do your work these studying get
ready then you know don't be afraid of
any of that you know the worst that can
happen if you go in an interview and you
don't do good is you don't get the job
you know you go to another interview
just you know all you can do is just try
to prepare as best you can
John B says what do you look for
specifically on a potential candidates
github profile yeah I I personally I
want to see what I want to see like what
have they worked on it does that relate
to the job that I'm actually hiring them
for and then I want to look at like how
many like how many commits are they how
consistent or the commits like have they
contribute if they've contributed to
other projects and open-source projects
that's a big plus if they've gotten
accept because that tells me that the
people that are in charge of these
open-source projects that are
maintaining them have thought that their
code was good enough to actually pull in
so that that's a big plus that's like a
vote of confidence from from people who
are established in the industry so
that's a big thing if you can get that
that would be impressive at least to me
and then other than that though just
seeing like you know what are you
working on or the projects good are you
showing improvement in which you're
working on things like that
Joseph says hi Jesse is it necessary to
know something about back-end or server
while you learn to be front-end and by
the way I'm overwhelmed I'm sorry you're
overwhelmed don't get too discouraged
about that just keep at it you'll get
less and less overwhelmed as you as you
go on and get more confident the if
you're learning front-end you you don't
have to know a lot about back-end it
just kind of depends on what you're
working on and so I would I would say
like if it interests you go ahead and
learn back-end but if you feel like you
have to learn back-end stuff to be good
with front-end stuff I don't think you
necessarily do and then if like if you
get a job where there's a back-end
people and front-end people and stuff
and you probably would never have to do
very much at all with a back-end but
like me with my job we don't have
back-end people here so I do have to do
some stuff with back-end so I can't say
for sure that you'll never need backend
because you certainly might but it's not
absolutely required
one ass or one one says in terms of like
the proper talking about free code camp
projects in different projects is you
can try to build something HTML J's
first then try to do the same with react
that's actually a really good I've done
that I did that with the weather app for
free code camp and it was really cool to
see the difference in terms of time for
development and then the final product
so that's really good advice thanks
thanks one okay so I am finally at the
end of this live chat this was like an
epic chat so we had significantly more
viewers today than we have and they were
really active in the chat so thank you
so much
I'm like really pumped that so many
people were interested in this and and
stuck around and contributed in the chat
I really appreciate that thanks everyone
for watching I'll be back tomorrow
like I said tomorrow will probably be an
early stream because I have a meeting at
my normal stream time so I will I will
put it on Twitter at the latest tomorrow
morning when I'm going to stream and I
will also schedule the stream so you'll
get it'll be on the YouTube channel for
free code camp so anyway thanks everyone
thanks for watching contributing and
have a great day I'll see you all
tomorrow